Ukraine this morning schools are closed
in case of new air attacks British
intelligence says fighting has
intensified in one area of eastern
Ukraine with Russian forces shelling the
town of buladar overnight officials say
Russia May launch new attacks there as
Charlie dagger reports Ukraine's first
lady is asking other world leaders to
take note of Russia's human rights
violations
via video link Elena zelenska gave the
U.N a harrowing account of the horrors
ukrainians have had to endure since
Russia invaded
these are human rights in any city of
Ukraine in London Berlin or New York she
said we have the right to live free not
to be killed or tortured it's a lesson
seven-year-old Sasha doesn't need to be
told he and his family fled from a
village in zapparesia Under Siege of
Russian soldiers
my grandma says that at any second they
could capture you tying you up and
subject you to electric shock that
sounds very scary so are Air Raids but
Sasha says he's used to it a UNICEF
report this week says children in
Ukraine have experienced a year of
horror at risk of depression anxiety
post-traumatic stress disorder and other
mental health issues
among those issues for psychologists
Cena levodiva counseling young girls who
feared being raped by Russian soldiers
I had teenage girls who told me yes we
were forced into the basement but for
some reason we started laughing she said
their way of dealing with it it worked
in that they started laughing
hysterically and were not touched
[Music]
children in need of help but more than
anything an end to hostilities
the air raid sirens have already gone
off here in the capital this morning a
defense official says a drone was
intercepted shot down by Ukraine's air
defense system Gail
children another reminder of the cost of
this war thank you Charlie dagada in
Ukraine